what's up it's the intro it's royal it's
rolling right is raw we're all rolling
here we go
[Music]
i don't know how to play guitar
is that a johnny cash song how's the
rising sun yeah
i'm missing a string there is
a house instantity
wow hey everybody welcome back to the
quarter podcast was that our intro
yeah was that our intro i'm missing a
string that sucks but it's cool it's the
intro
we know you guys don't come here for the
intros but they do brighten up your day
so everyone jake has uh recently had a
baby uh
that's right that's the big announcement
a little girl named claire
and that is why we were without his
banjo tunes at the beginning of this
podcast
that's right she was born just a few
days ago right mm-hmm yeah surprise
everyone
jake just had his third baby yeah he's
got three of them now
yeah it's not gonna do three two one for
the number of babies three two one zero
three two one zero it's a beautiful
perfect countdown i do wonder who
the next person at corridor to have a
child will be who knows
who else probably someone who's married
not necessarily no one here has children
out of wedlock in the studio
we have a very it's in our mission
statement
[Laughter]
we're a strict catholic organization
yeah probably dean
[Laughter]
young father young child beater dean
father
oh shoot maybe he shouldn't
uh that's such an unfortunate nickname
that we've given him sorry it's only
because he
beats up ness and all the smash brothers
games aka clint
and i guess we'll talk a lot more about
that in the next podcast
yeah the next pros next podcast will be
about our office culture and why
smash has become the dominant part of it
don't worry if you're not into smash
it'll still be a good podcast
because you're gonna hear more about
rivalries and fights
and all that good stuff than you've ever
thought possible but
that's not what we're talking about in
this podcast what are we talking about
today nico in this podcast
we're going to talk about something that
we touched upon in a recent visual
effects artist react episode that i've
really been wanting to talk about more
it's the idea of visual effects that
don't have impact versus visual effects
that do have impact
and kind of the idea of you know a
company spending
all this time and money and manpower and
talent on visual effects
but other things around that aren't
necessarily executed to the same degree
you know when you go and you watch a
cool movie and there's a simple vfx shot
and it hits you emotionally
why does that hit you so emotionally
versus other times you go and you watch
say like you know a giant superhero
movie and don't get me wrong there's
effect shots in superhero movies that
are mind-blowing also
but there'll be crazy shots that just
kind of fly by and you don't feel
anything
and it feels like you know you have 500
amazing artists working on one shot and
like three artists working on another
shot
and somehow the art the other shot with
just a couple artists
can be better now that's not always the
case but yeah i want to talk a little
bit about this
strange disconnect that you see in films
especially these days between
you know visual effects and spectacle
versus like something actually gripping
you emotionally and why that happens and
how it can be you know addressed and all
that
yeah i mean who has the answers to that
one well like a
i mean separate from the story side of
things just when you have an entire
movie that's
visual effects basically any marvel film
in the last 10 years
uh it's you know it's just an onslaught
of just
constant vfx shots it's like it's we're
getting to a point where there's parity
between the number of
shots in a movie and the number of
visual effects shots in that same movie
like films are practically
practically the same right yeah
practically animated well that's great
because it comes full circle and it's
not visual effects based anymore in a
weird way where it's just like
here's the story and we need visual
effects to tell it
and it's not like a thing that's
impressing anyone anymore
but i i touched on this in my ted talk
last year a little bit about that
because it's like you know the monster
flicks the
the action films the or the destruction
films you know like uh
was it 2012 yeah battle la uh yeah i
mean
that new one with the rock or like san
andreas or whatever you know like
on the surface the movie is not hiding
what it's trying to be it's supposed to
be like a popcorn action flick turn off
your brain quote unquote and just enjoy
the houdini simulations yeah
which don't get me wrong i enjoy that
song i'm into that too yeah
i prefer that in a in a non-story sense
like i'd prefer to watch
just a vfx breakdown reel of san andreas
rather than actually watching
san andreas i mean but like 2012
is awesome you know it's like but those
movies solve the problem
that like superhero movies have which is
like
oh we have to have a it has to be a
really big deal when this whole like
city simulation
explosion thing happens and those movies
are just like no that's
that's like every scene every scene is
just another insane
2012 was directed by arguably the master
of disaster films
roland emmerich yeah the same man that
brought you independence day
did he direct that or produce it he
directed it he directed
it but uh this reminds me of the one of
the best uh
definitions or analogies i've heard
about the idea of
diminishing returns and let's say you
have 10
chocolate bars and you have to eat all
10.
great that sounds amazing right i get to
eat candy bars because i have to
fantastic well the first one is
delicious the second one is also pretty
good the third one
you're like okay i'll finish this one
the fourth one you're starting to be
like
you know you take it or leave it but you
finish it and then the fifth one
you're only halfway through all the
candy bars you got to eat but the fifth
one you're showing me like i'm kind of
done
i don't want any more then the sixth one
you're just like vomiting
yeah you know it's also like the the
saturation of like
spectacle shots and movies kind of
reminds me of like imagine you're
watching a david blaine
magic special right i love david play i
love david blaine too he's amazing he
turns the camera and he goes all right
watch this i'm gonna give this person a
deck of cards we're gonna take one card
out of it they're not gonna show me any
of it
i'm just gonna tell them what card it is
it's gonna blow their minds he goes all
right
he sets it up and he works the mood and
he hands him the deck and like no way
he's gonna pull us off he's set up
he's set up the craziest situation and
then the person takes out a car and just
goes it's the five of clubs the person's
like oh my god it is they turn around
you're like wow
that's crazy how do you do that trick
now that's cool right that'd be a really
cool
i honestly think there is nothing cooler
than watching like proximity magic
tricks
right like now imagine instead though
if the david blaine magic special is him
just going up to a person back think of
a card five of clubs think of a card
jacket diamonds think of a card ten of
spades think of a card ace of hearts and
everyone's like wow that's it
it was just that over and over for like
an hour because that's
still magic and it's still a crazy
effect but
it's like oh okay there pump the brakes
buddy like
cool you're guessing cards and i don't
know how you're doing it but man you're
hitting me with a lot of card guesses
all at the same time and just
there's no story and you're not pulling
me into it i feel like it's the same
thing with visual effects
you know these days at least in those
big films where it's just like
man after the 800th explosion on screen
it's like
yeah candy bars well this all started
because we were watching
tron for visual effects artists react
and depending on when this podcast goes
up
that visual effects react episode may or
may not already be online
probably not yet what's close to it if
it's not out yet it's coming very
quickly yeah so yeah we did a whole
episode talking about
the original tron in 1982 compared to
the most recent tron which came out in
basically a complete 30-year gap between
the two movies
and a lot of technical achievements that
happened in between
yeah and one of the things that we're
looking at was you know there's a couple
of shots in the original tron
that are very basic shots but they have
a lot of impact um i mean they're not
all necessarily that basic but they're
like they're very focused
and when they they pop onto the screen
you're like wow that's really cool
and there's the later tron which does
don't get me wrong does have some cool
shots
but there's a lot of shots that are like
mind-blowing technical achievements but
they don't hit the same way
as the shots in the first tron the
question is why is that
why don't they hit the same way so i i
wonder
if maybe they kind of do but then they
just never let up so it's like the first
time you go into the tron world
especially if you've been watching the
movie and not just like you know
skipping through it for
a vfx artist's reaction so you're like
in the world you just spent the last you
know 15 20 minutes in the real life and
all the
political company stuff that whatever
happens in that movie right
and then all of a sudden bam cool neon
lights
all around the world you're like whoa
but then
the movie has to maintain that world
though you know they can't just be like
hey
visual effects shot that's that was cool
right well now uh that's all you get
you know i mean it it happens once in
the film and it's in the very beginning
and it's like yeah there's plot
exposition
he gets zapped into the movie and then
regardless of how good the movie is
really you know what i mean how good the
exposition and the story is
that first moment when those like little
inquisitors or whatever they're called
excavators steel inquisitors
uh recognizers recognizers yeah those
are the
little blocky staple spaceships the
staples
the flying stables picked up on that and
flies into the city
that's awesome you know and and it comes
down to like
like regardless of how much you're into
the story
that one works because that's why you
turned the movie on
you know you wanted to see that moment
we're in real life and now
we're in this crazy new universe and so
that's satisfying
on all levels no matter who you are
because you've made it this far in the
film you've
that's the shot you've came here to see
you know
so what about them light cycles well but
that's the thing
that's also where it ends too you know
what i mean
like now we're here yay the big reveal
it's over and now something else has to
drive this film other than
look at this new cool reveal this next
area
or thing or whatever because we're there
you know
there's no it's like disney world wow
disney world it's like
15 minutes of exposition we're going to
disney world we got our tickets you take
time off school kids yes we did oh here
we go
we're on the plane we're coming here
disney world yeah it's like boom and
it's like well
now what happens now you're gonna just
like just constantly show huge reveal
shots of disney world like
for another like hour you know it's it's
like
there's something else has to happen i
mean i did really enjoy the light cycle
sequence as
as a sequence within the movie but i
think the main problem
with the movie is that the actual story
and plot
doesn't match that level of like world
building which
is all the time yeah avatar is my
biggest disappointment in that regard
i loved avatar i'm not saying it's a bad
movie that that's that's the thing
freddy said it best he says
a simple story told well is better than
a complicated story that might be better
but not told well exactly yeah and it's
not even about expectations or anything
it's just simply like
setting up characters and stakes that
you want to see happen or achieved or
whatever
and they can be simple i mean i i i
watched avatar
and i liked it you know it was it was
cool it was fun to watch
it's it wasn't i wasn't like this is a
stupid movie blah blah fish people you
know
but a lot of people did think it was a
stupid movie nico you just said that you
were disappointed in it
uh why was that yeah well my
disappointment came came from the realm
of
you know they developed this visual
technology and all the surrendering
capability
and spending years on it yeah i spent
years on it
um to just you know to give me the same
kind of reheated storyline
and you know it feels like the story and
the time that went to the script it
feels like
one or two people maybe three or four
sat down for a couple months
and wrote the script and they had like a
thousand people sit down for five years
and do the visual effects
and just the the imbalance there is what
disappoints me because i end up seeing a
film that
is visually stunning with like visuals
that are far beyond anything else that's
ever been in theaters
but i've seen the story before i've seen
it a million times there wasn't really
anything inventive about it and like i
get it that some people are like they're
cool with that i mean
there's some inventive stuff in it
actually yeah
there's like inventive moments like
there's concepts which are like this
whole like
like body uh like hosting like
a host body kind of concept like an
avatar and like
yeah like transferring your mind and
like
fun scenes that play off of that like
where one person's
trapped in stasis controlling a body
that's elsewhere and they're like
helpless and coming you know it's like
there is like there yeah there's sci-fi
concepts that we have
quote unquote seen in other stories but
compared to like
what like avengers which is like
a big portal you know
you know what i'm saying like yeah it's
like
yeah i think the best example
of what what i feel like needs to happen
in the industry
is what happened with uh spider-man into
the spider-verse
you know there's a story that is truly
unique there is no other spider-man
story like that unless it's been pulled
from a comic book but obviously that's
something i'm referring to like there's
not another movie where it's like oh
yeah that's this plot from spider-verse
like
you know the spider-verse story is
wholly unique to that movie
and then it is paired with visuals that
are also wholly unique to that movie and
it feels like the amount of effort that
went into conceiving the film
equals the amount of effort that went
into visually directing the film sure
but i could also say spider-verse has
been done before it's like bill hasn't
bill and ted's excellent adventure it's
not really the same you know it's like
it's like kind of similar where it's
like there's a
diverse concept where you're drawing
characters from different
universes into your it's like you know i
don't know about it i don't know about
that
those are pretty like they're maybe
roughly
similar from like a vague distance if
you squint your eyes they're not nearly
as similar as avatar and pocahontas
sure or the other 10 films that follow
the same plot i know but but do you want
a thousand people to write a story
you know i mean like you want thousands
of people in thousands of hours
to make this collaborative document that
kind of gets
probably washed out and evened out by
like too many voices
what i want is a story that has as much
creativity and refinement
and inventiveness and achievement as
the visual effects do you know like you
name a movie that has
all that inventiveness i just did
spider-verse
spider-man into the spider-verse well
it's just it's just a kid who has
self-esteem issues and his high school
problems
has different spider-man help him
you know not exactly have you seen the
movie
yeah i mean that's kind of it it's
basically i'm spider-man
also they are also spider-man i mean to
me i think and this is a little bit of a
departure i love the movie i love you
but i'm just trying to get a little
reductive to like play around here with
this idea
i feel like generally any any good
sci-fi movie in my opinion
needs to have a premise that creates a
story that can only exist with that
premise
like you're going to make a weird
premise like let's say you do the matrix
right the world is a simulation and you
go in there and you tell
a romantic comedy that has nothing to do
with the simulation
then it's like why does this exist as a
sci-fi film you know and i feel like a
lot of films
end up falling into that where they
create these crazy worlds and the story
they go and they do
doesn't need that world to exist the
story could exist without that world
and to me it's just because they're kind
of just writing by the numbers when they
write the script
um whereas there's there's films like
you know spider-man the spider-verse
that cannot exist without the world
of the spider-verse world you know like
this the avatar story
can kind of exist without the the avatar
world to some degree
um it just needs to be you know one
person visiting another group of people
and they're at different technology
levels and
so on and so forth and you have a war
because one side has the resources the
other
you know wants but like you know to take
this back to tron
you know you see his crazy visual
effects but the story is just like
characters looking for his dad just like
they
the creativity on one level doesn't
match up with the creativity on the
other level and
to me it's a little bit of a tragic
thing about modern filmmaking is that
that kind of occurs
in films you have just these like
massive
human achievements combined with just by
the numbers
script writing it happens with video
games too all the time
how much of that do you think is because
writing is
way more difficult than most people
realize it's incredibly hard
yeah like good writing is incredibly
hard
uh because it's it's hard to judge how
good something is when it's
when it's like so implicitly uh
judged you know it's like it's hard to
tell the difference betw like what is
better between these two amazing scripts
it's like which one's better it's hard
to say
whereas with visual effects you know
it's a little easier to judge
how good they are because it's like is
it realistic
is it impactful like there's a there's a
bunch of explicit uh check boxes that
you can
check off when it comes to something
like how something looks i totally agree
i think i think a lot of people really
do underestimate how hard writing is
i think the other thing that people
underestimate also within the industry
is to be a good writer to be a truly
truly good writer
like accomplished you can't just write
you need to shoot
you need to direct you need to act you
need to have experienced filmmaking
because
films are not a written medium they're a
visual medium
and if as a writer you only exist in the
written world
you won't write a good film because
films need to have
images paired like a good film can
usually be told
without words you know so a good writer
should be able to write a movie
without dialogue but if if you don't
have an idea of how to visually tell a
story if you don't have an idea of how
to pull these different units together
if you don't have an idea of how an
actor puts a twist on a character
if you basically don't know how the
system works it's hard to write and a
lot of times
you know at least some some starting
writers don't necessarily have that full
breadth of achievement of experience
which it's obviously it takes years and
years and years to build up something
like that
sure yeah i mean it's it's it's so it's
a really subjective thing
ultimately i feel like it's i think when
i think
just going back to this tron example
like
i think you can boil it down to
just the fact that the story here is
it's
i think the south park guys had the
whole like you know
but kind of like writing rule where it's
like what
the butt writing rule where you want to
be stringing your
events and moments together with the
word butt
like are we talking once this happened
but
then this happened okay versus this
happened and then this happened
because the word but basically implies
well something unexpected is going to
come up here so the conflict
improv when you have like yes and you
know you're always trying to add
something to the scene
so that's like another version of that i
guess right exactly and it's not just
about additive story here where it's
it's about like actual expectations and
stuff like that and you know the tron
movie is
i think the and version where
from the onset of the piece there is
every
the first time you meet characters they
are clearly defined for the rest of the
piece
you know there's there's not like
there's like a little backstabbing here
and there maybe
yeah not really but it's basically
here's a bunch of clearly defined
characters
we know exactly what they want and how
they're going to act in all these
situations
and then we just throw scenes into the
pot
and everything is exactly how you expect
it to go and then it ends
and so you're not invested you're not
surprised your expectations
are not met so on and so forth
well once again it's that time in the
podcast where i tell you about today's
episode sponsor
storyblocks now you may have noticed
they keep sponsoring this podcast and
that's because they keep offering
an awesome tool for content creators do
you have an instagram account do you
post photos or videos on
it do you have a youtube channel are you
an aspiring filmmaker are you a
filmmaker already
well guess what storyblocks has
something for everybody
in those categories they are the one
stop shop for all of your stock asset
needs they have
b-roll after effects templates sound
effects
motion graphics and more it's all
royalty free and it comes in
high quality 4k they also are constantly
updating their site and their library
with new footage and new assets
and the best part is with an all-access
plan you get unlimited downloads that
can be used
for any type of project so whether it's
a commercial or it's something for
youtube that you're monetizing or
whatever it might be you download it you
put it in your video
and you move on with your day that's a
lot of information but if you guys are
interested
head on over to storybox.com court or
cast
if you've already been there and you've
already signed up well then i mean tell
a friend you better have learned a
lesson here i want you to know
storybox is the one stop shop for all
your stock asset needs
storybox.comcast back to the podcast
so in the example of uh tron legacy what
would be the difference between story
and plot
i mean it's so hard to and we're getting
like okay well then
kind of gets into the weeds in general
what's like the biggest uh
defining factor of okay story or plot
okay so plot is oh now we have to race
these motorcycles
now we have to throw frisbees now uh
there's secret agents in our nightclub
now there is this you know it's like
those that's plot basically
events you know these are like kind of
some kinds of events wikipedia entries
well it's like let's say i'm designing a
dnd campaign where i'm like all right
well
there's a motorcycle race track over
here if they wish to compete you know
they can sign up for that
we have another event over here there's
a frisbee game here and there's also a
nightclub here
and i have maybe a cool thing planned
where like maybe the bad guys will
attack them
in this area but they can go through the
stuff in any order they want whatever
but the story is what drives them
to get there and what drives them to go
to the next place it's not just like
you guys want to race motorcycles sure
you know
let's let's let's race okay it's not
like
it's like we have to race these
motorcycles or else
blank you know or we need to win the
trophy because within that trophy is the
key
i need a thousand dollars to buy some
new bones
and it just so happens that it will win
a thousand dollars by entering this
light cycle competition
thousand dollars is enough to get you 10
sets of bones it's like
yeah it's like it's like yeah exactly i
know
as per the canon i know i slipped up on
that one but it's
you know the story is the thing that
goes beyond these events the thing that
pulls you into them and then through
them and then on to the next thing
and you know like i think that's
that's my definition anyways it's like
the guy who
whatever he didn't teleport into the
tron universe to race light cycle bikes
he wasn't like you know what's gonna be
sweet throwing frisbees and motorcycles
you know you know no that wasn't it yet
when those scenes come up it feels kind
of like
so yeah why are we doing this again that
makes sense to me so it's it's story is
i mean everyone always says the story is
the most important factor of a movie or
any sort of
story but like
i think that's just accentuated here
because i feel like the story of tron
legacy wasn't strong enough to justify
the the plot or the world or everything
around the majesty of the visuals
yeah yeah exactly because i i love the
aesthetic of tron legacy i thought it
was super cool
yes exactly that's why i went to see it
i was like i want to see what this dude
yeah when that movie first got like
announced or rather when the like the
trailers were dropping
just leading up to the movie actually
coming out like everyone was so hyped
daft punk did the entire score everyone
loved daft punk
uh this movie was gonna be amazing and
then everyone was kind of just like
eh yeah i mean the scene but it's like
it looks so good
how could you possibly have that
reaction of er i know right because
it doesn't matter unless the story's
good exactly you gave me too many candy
bars
when we were reviewing the scene in the
nightclub where there's like the ninja
fight
every single time it cut to the daft
punk guys like bobbing their heads up in
the little window it's like
they could have replaced that with a
billboard that said pepsi
you know what i mean and i would have
felt the exact same way like why are you
cutting to this
like okay i get it they're here like
okay you know it's like
it felt like a brand like a sponsorship
of the film or something you know what i
mean where it's like
you're not like cool there they are it's
like i mean kinda that was the
it's like cool it's just placed poorly
it's just placement it's without
intention
it's basically product placement in a
weird way where it's
completely irrelevant to anything that's
happening like if they would have maybe
like
been involved period beyond just like
like just that like maybe a scene where
they have to get a microchip from their
dj
station or some crap you know or like i
mean turn up the music so that like some
guy can't tell it was just like no these
people are fighting for their lives
apparently because one of them is trying
to find their father and you're cutting
to daft punk bobbing their heads like
nothing's happening
also don't forget through the entirety
of that sequence everyone's like
fighting and dying that one dude uh
there's a shot of a person
crying and picking up the pieces of the
loved ones
who this character is and why he's just
so nonchalant about all that but like
whatever i forget i forget the dude's
name he's he's been in a lot of things
uh like underworld anyway he yeah he was
just like
ah yeah it felt weird
yeah i think it was just that disconnect
once again between like
the artistry going to one aspect of the
film was not matched by like the
artistry going to the other aspect of
the film like
the effort that went into like how can
we incorporate death punk into the scene
like that was a one minute decision as i
just cut to them
yeah how much of that is due to the
director versus the the writing
probably a bunch well and the producers
most likely
sure yeah i mean it's a relationship for
sure but like
i don't know like after being through
this stupid process so many times at
this point it's like you
it's like if you have the forethought if
you have the time to really think about
stuff before
going onto a set like this you can
usually make that kind of stuff
work or figure it out so it's placed in
a way that
makes sense well that's also assuming
you have the freedom to then make the
change
because that's the thing is like you go
on to that set and you're like okay we
got daft punk today
uh how can we incorporate them you know
just in the script it just said insert
daft punks i was like okay now we're on
set and here's daft punk how can i
incorporate them
it's like will be cool if i did this
maybe i could do this okay let's let's
tweak these shots let's add this we'll
take the script but
you don't get any of that freedom in a
film like this when things are that
expensive yeah and i wonder if it's
something this is obviously
pure un uh just
speculation here i'm making this up but
like what if it was something along the
lines of all right
death punk it was in their agreement
their contract that like
they just had a cameo no no
much involvement in the movie uh they
would score the whole thing they just
had to be in the film for a little bit
and maybe they were just like we don't
want to do anything more than just kind
of sit here and dj
yeah why not pick a funnier scene or a
better scene to do that than like
some a life or death situation because
it'd probably be like out of place
here's how i would be how much funnier
if they go to jeff bridges house in the
cyber verse
and they're just like playing beats in
the background what's up guys and that's
it
right great what a baller
he just has them trapped in a box
playing music from
it's like that's way funnier no i i
actually agree with you
that's a good solution or you know if
you gotta keep in the nightclub scene
use them in the intro of the nightclub
scene
you know dude walks on the floor
everything's dark boom daft bunk hits
play lights come on people start dancing
like sick
it's a nightclub with daft punk okay
continue this scene you know that at
least would incorporate them
into the emotional flow yeah the scene i
guess what i'm getting at is we have no
idea what's
going on dictating the terms behind the
scenes right but i think it's who knows
regardless of that it's you know it's no
excuses filmmaking at the end of the day
the product is the product yeah you know
i agree you know i feel like
there's another aspect of this too like
in terms of getting people to be
impressed by your visuals which is we've
experienced this with
videos on corridor if we make something
so polished or too polished
people critique it on a different level
like we've had people say like your
effects are better than hollywood
which objectively is not true
no it's i always feel embarrassed when i
see those comments like oh you guys are
doing better than
hollywood i'm like i don't think you
know what you're talking about
but don't don't get me wrong though
there are effect shots in hollywood
movies
that don't look as good as effect shots
that we have done i would agree with
that
yeah you know there's we've had cg blend
better than you know cg and hollywood
films but from an overall standpoint
especially from a technical standpoint
the effects in hollywood are better
i mean the vfx supervisor at weta
digital matt aiken complimented us on
our boss town video he was like that was
an
amazing video you guys know what you're
doing the visual effects hold up
yeah all right better this is the guy
who oversaw avengers
yeah which is great it's amazing it's
super flattering though the thing is
what's weird is when you step your
your polish down a little bit and
becomes a little more amateur and you
can kind of feel like oh it's a dude who
made this
like that's when people say our effects
are better than hollywood and then when
we step our game up and we get really
polished and we try to bring it to
hollywood level that's when people go
ah it's not as good well give me an
example of that i mean
what exactly what's that shadow of
mordor shadow of order yeah
sure it was i don't think it was the
effects necessarily in that piece or
people pointing out like clint's foot
clipping
on the robot in the first boss town
dynamics video oh yeah yeah you know
it's
i mean there's yeah there's always
examples sure there's errors and stuff
i think it's just really just the thing
of like who are you competing with so to
speak where it's like if you're
it's not just the effects itself but
it's like the concept of the whole
production word yeah you invite i mean
you invite that level of scrutiny when
you
try to make it if you're trying to go
this is real you know like
that that means if you're saying this is
real either it's a parody
well not a parody but it's like you're
trying to literally fool someone into
thinking it's real like the boss town
videos
which he successfully did so we're great
but the thing is when it comes to like
stuff that's truly narrative not like
yeah okay here's a video with jokes ha
ha this is funny the end
like that's not it it's like the shadow
of mordors of the world or the stuff
where it's like
here's a new universe believe it's real
we're going to bring you on a little
journey through this universe and then
something weird
looking pops up that's not utterly
convincing
it shakes the whole thing up and you're
out and so it really depends on like
where you are in that narrative ladder
from like
like parody or comedy to like something
that's dramatic
that i think is what's truly dictating
it
so like what's an example of a serious
short film
that has a lot of visual effects that
are meant to be like
high grade like this is supposed to be
pretty good uh
versus fart attack well that one's
clearly
it can be anything it wants to because
it's farting on the street flying around
like knowing i mean the realism there is
is like less of a matter than just the
concept in a weird way well
no my point is because of the nature of
that video you can you we could have had
way crappier effects in that film no
problem intended
oh my god but like they
they could have been worse you know and
the video would have been just as good
although part of the video was like oh
wow look at those smoke simulations that
was kind of
part of the video right the other half i
mean sometimes the other the other half
of this is
sometimes things get funnier if you do
put more work into them
where it's like here's a video about
guys farting and check this out we're
gonna
take our computers here and set up some
semi-advanced like
smoke simulations that are gonna take
hours and hours to simulate or vape god
yeah or vape
you know it's like there's something
funny behind with like seeing a dumb
concept like brought to a point of like
excellence of in some way you know where
you're like
i'd say we excel over here at corridor
that's our bread and butter taking a
stupid concept and making it epic yeah
exactly but that's part of the comedy
which is seeing how over the top
you can get but you uh you do lose
something when
you make something so polished and so
refined that
you lose the concept of an artist being
behind it like
yeah when you can see like oh one person
did this and this is really good
i could theoretically do it if i spent
as much time learning how to use the
program as that person did versus
this was made by literally 500 people
and i have no concept of how this is
made
it's cool-looking but like i can't feel
the human i mean but are you what are
you okay so let's say
uh okay give me a movie that's too
polished well no i think maybe that's
cute
you're like should avatar have been like
or maybe maybe clue and
tron the head should have been like 21
frames per second and skip frames every
once in a while
i think more more to the point is like
for example or like the textures can of
get low-res when you get close
if i showed you a single frame from the
avengers not from like the big epic
final shot but just
any part of the movie that's just a
technical achievement but you know it's
like
a java spaceship right if i show you
that one frame and then you sit down and
watch somebody take a pencil and draw a
photoreal rendering of a person's head
roughly in 20 minutes
you're going to have a more of an
emotional response to that 20-minute
pencil drawing
versus that frame that took literal
months of man-hours when you combine it
together but are you just 10
right
here where you know it's it's one person
produce this thing that's why you have
suburbs like top town or whatever you
know where it's like
so cool this one person was able to do
this thing in theory
this person did this so i could too yeah
so if one person made the avengers
whereas like it would be better
ten people maybe a thousand people made
this i couldn't do that because a
thousand people are required
but if one person made the avengers it
would be so inspiring
of course so captivated also like like
just an anomaly
that would never happen again but you
would say holy [ __ ] every time like a
new shot came on which is kind of what
happens when you watch any of the ian
hubert's stuff
sure yeah well i mean i kind of
experienced a little bit of that back in
2013 when i came out with my harry
potter
short film you know it was like i spent
half a year on that thing it had over
100 vfx shots
smoke sims and all that stuff and it was
like it was a pretty polished short film
i
i feel like i've come a long way since
then but the point is that i think
a lot of people knew it was basically
just me who made that video
and so the whole time watching it
they're like oh wow one person made this
yeah it kind of changes your
interpretation of what you're seeing
you you tend to be a lot uh more
forgiving
on mistakes and like visual things like
oh yeah it's a little amateur but hey it
was just one person so
look but look at all all this other
stuff they did yeah is that something
that's just something that
uh is more of an aspirational aspect to
it because like obviously we
make videos and do this kind of stuff so
if i see someone like i see one guy
do something incredible i see like peter
releases a funny like
video i'm like wow i know one guy made
all that and that's impressive because
i want to get better at making this kind
of stuff too it's like
i would say it's not just it feels like
an aspirational element like
you know viewers on youtube want to make
videos the reason i say it's not just
aspirational is because you have the
same effect when you watch jackie chan
fight scenes
okay this is just a human operating at
the top of their capability
and it's super entertaining watching
this person do what they do best
versus like if it is like many fight
scenes now it is super polish
covered from 100 different angles hyper
edited crazy sound design
it can be cool if there's other context
around it like if it's creatively cool
and it's executing something that's
you know visually been never been like
directed before
you know that's one thing but if it's
just a fight scene it has zero impact
versus like you go to that old school
fight scene you know it's jackie chan
doing something it has so much more
impact yeah i know i mean i'm not saying
it's a human touch it's the
touch of the artist i i don't disagree
with that's the concept of that
statement but what i do disagree is the
fact that there's
one thing that's better than the other
because i
they're like separate concepts like i
watched
blade runner the new one i saw it twice
in theaters
you saw it twice in theaters yeah
because the first time i saw it
it was so amazing that when i heard you
see it again more more
more guys were going out to see it nico
and like mike and jan were seeing again
i was like
yeah i want to see that movie again and
i watched it again i was like this is
even better
well i just realized you said blade
runner not blade blade
but like we go see blade there's there's
no human touch on that film i disagree
oh blade runner yeah 2049 i mean call it
call it what you want but i wouldn't
describe it as the human
like the painterly touch i didn't see
the brush strokes
i mean there's a little bit of the roger
deacon's touch
maybe it's roger deakin but actually he
knows how to film stuff you know what
mean i actually i do agree
it's great cinematography you don't see
the hand of the artist in blade runner
20 49 but that takes us back to the
beginning of this which is
blade runner 2049 has creative
saturation throughout it's not a generic
script with really good cinematography
it's not a boring movie with good visual
effects the whole thing
is through and through creatively
executed all the way down to every
single detail
so yeah the the crazy visual effects are
justified
by also having a crazy story in a crazy
world and crazy like crazy everything
yeah i mean but another factor on top of
that is is the fact that like
every shot looks amazing just from like
a pure
like artistical beauty standpoint as
opposed to like a technical achievement
i mean isn't tron like that or something
not always
a little bit but like that's the other
thing is like with with blade runner 20
49 sometimes the shot's pretty
just because they put the camera in the
right spot and it has nothing to do with
how many people worked on it it's just
them going
yeah lower the camera two feet it's a
better angle oh and maybe just haze it
up a little bit
perfect you're like that's a beautiful
shot the composition is stunning
and all i did was pick a lens and pick a
camera position you know there's not
500 people working months and months and
months to deliver that shot to you
again we're coming back to my ted talk
it's like because that won the visual
effects oscar
uh was that movie but the other big
contender was uh war for the planet of
the apes the third planet apes movie you
know and it's like
the effects in that movie in my opinion
were far better
but it's just a bunch of monkeys walking
around i guess yeah
maybe from a technical standpoint
there's more advanced things going on
there but
the thing is i mean maybe it is just a
cinematography thing at that rate
because it's like
it's not about the visual effects but
it's just like you know how do you
capture it
and convey it to an audience it comes
down to the fact that it's like
blade runner kind of just it engulfs you
inside of its
movie and its world so well that you
just kind of forget that anytime you're
seeing like the spaceship walk flying
around the spaceship walking around
or or like the little hologram lady like
phasing through him and
and whatnot like you never really
consider like oh yeah that's a visual
effect you're like oh yeah
that hologram man that would be cool to
have as opposed to like
war for the planet apes you're
constantly looking at these apes
acting you're like wow that ape has some
really good eye animation that's cool
[Laughter]
yeah you know it kind of like there's an
analogy that comes to mind
so i just saw the ford versus ferrari
movie and they bring up how like well at
ford
it's an assembly line and every person
has a job one person tightens the bolts
the other person polishes the chrome the
other person
airbrushes the fender i don't i'm just
making these jobs up i don't know how
cars made
but you know it goes down the assembly
line each each person is just part of an
assembly line
whereas at ferrari one person makes the
entire engine
of a car you know so it's like each
person makes one car
so it's not what you know it's not a car
passing through 100 different hands
it's one car in one hand until the car
is basically finished you know i'm
simplifying a little bit but it's you
know it kind of brings to mind this
whole visual effects thing like these
days visual effects are basically a
factory line where
a single shot passes through the hands
of hundreds of people
right hundreds but what are you doing
with this yeah absolutely but if you see
another shot where it's just
one craftsman maybe with help of a
couple other has made that one
shot it hits you differently you know it
feels like it's a work of art the other
one feels like a product
i think that kind of goes back to what
we're talking about with writing and why
it's just one person who writes
something versus
a committee yeah uh
i think the other thing with writing too
though is that like especially these
days because you know
writing making movies is a business
decision yeah at least big movies are
you know so it's
when when a movie gets greenlit like it
wasn't like somebody
went you know what god i love tron
and i just have this i have this idea
i've been working on for years
of another story in tron i would just i
just need the opportunity
like that's not how tron started tron
started with somebody going
what's an ip that i have yeah that i can
revisit it's more like yeah
that's about time we made another tron
movie so uh yeah any ideas i'm gonna
hire you and you to write tron
cool thanks i guess i'll just put a
story together
and okay oh [ __ ] what do i need 10 pages
i need like one of those scenes that
gets
you know gets me from here to here i'll
just open my let's see my book of movie
scenes i'll use that scene i'll
change the names yeah you know and so a
guy delivers a script in a couple months
and then they go off and they make the
movie you know it's the same thing
happened with like
you know i don't know there's lots of
films where they're literally they write
the script in like
a couple months i mean the second star
wars heck all the star wars movies that
recently came out are perfect examples
of that i would disagree with there
not all of them well not
at least than the the main three that
came out i would still disagree
one of them i think stands out i mean
ryan are you talking about ryan johnson
i am
i mean it's still like it could have
been better
and the reason because that is like they
bring ryan johnson on like okay you got
a couple months to bang this out we
shoot on this date
he had a lot of time to work on it the
problem there was that he had a lot of
oversight from disney
right well they also didn't have any
plan for all three movies either you
know no one sat down and did the
creative leg work before deciding they
want to make a star wars movie star wars
wasn't created
because someone said i have these
stories i need to tell star wars was
created because i go we need some money
to make
yeah it's time to make some star wars
now i gotta make some stuff i do 100
agree with you there and
and that's what frustrated me so much
about the entire trilogy is the fact
that like the third movie just kind of
like
retconned a lot of the stuff in the
second movie is like oh actually
we're going to go this way and like
you're so so
obvious it was so stupid recently that
they were even like
shooting they had already begun shooting
and ray uh didn't know for a fact
whether or not
uh palpatine was gonna be her
grandfather or not like jj was like oh
yeah
he'll be he's your granddaddy and then
like a couple weeks later i was like oh
actually uh
we don't know yet we we're still working
on that and it's like that is the
perfect
example of how there wasn't a through
line outline for the entire like
story to build out from there there
wasn't a story that needed to be told no
one had created a story that they needed
to tell
instead they just said we need to make a
star wars movie let's start making up a
story
so we can do it which is you don't get
great
stories that way necessarily yeah it's
pretty stupid the only thing
good in that movie was when like in the
beginning she goes to like the palpatine
like
cryo chamber and it was so awesome and
epic
i didn't watch the third one i kind of
refused to i after that scene we
we we were dealing with kids and stuff
so we didn't finish it but
that was awesome it was like it was it
was like she's walking around there's
like giant like monolith like towers and
fog and stuff and it's like all
lightning and stuff and you're like wow
this is like dark souls in the future
it was so sick and then then
there's like a then they go to like
burning man
[Laughter]
which is inconsequential and then also
chewbacca dies
and then doesn't die and then exactly
they're like chewbacca no you're driving
on the wrong
boom which was a very cool moment it was
like because they were having like this
force pull moment like pulling the [ __ ]
back and forth and then she accidentally
blows it up with freaking force
lightning killing chewie
rig kills chewie and i was like oh my
god that was such a big deal
and literally the very next scene ha
psych chewie's on the other ship
he was like why are you doing that such
that's such lazy storytelling yeah it's
just like oh yeah it's like how did he
get there it was like no he was
there they were all just wrong actually
they all the characters
all the entire ensemble cast including
chewie's best friends like they just it
was a big mix-up
there was there was no clever escape he
just
they they just got mixed up quick but
it's no big deal
did not there was a little crying a lot
of tears
someone probably had a small heart
attack turns out
yeah they just got a yeah i mean yeah i
i definitely do not
uh disagree that there are a tremendous
number of problems with the story
of the new star wars movies yeah so
how do you make visual effects shots
have an impact how do you
not have it just be another step
to waste another couple seconds for
somebody to get
well it's easier when you have a smaller
budget
because then you have to pick and choose
when your visual effects happen
and that is something we've always done
at corridor or on corridor videos at
least it's like all right
three moments that's all you get yeah
and with like little vfx
shots sprinkled in but like there's
usually just like one cool moment
a second cooler moment and then a third
ultra cool moment
and where like all the effort goes into
these are your set pieces and it's like
you know those are the ones that are
gonna take your time uh
and what makes those cool is that all of
the shots
preceding it and following it aren't
that cool
so it's immediately standing out as whoa
this is different
so i don't know part of it i think for
us is
that's how you set shots apart to make
them look cool
yeah you need you need dynamics and
contrast it's the same thing with like
with like a hit you know or a gunshot if
your soundtrack is just
and there's a gunshot well you can't
hear it you know he's like
and then it sounds loud and it has an
impact you know the same thing goes for
visuals
for beef moment the screen needs to go
dark and then you throw a visual effects
shot on the screen
it's like a bad horror movie it's the
visual equivalent of a horror movie
you slowly fade out the footage and
there's a really bright shot you're like
oh
but actually actually they do do that
that works all the time
um so uh movies like avengers
and whatnot i keep saying avengers but
i'm i'm mostly referring to the two
final ones infinity war and in game you
know it's like
i thought those movies were very good
movies i totally agree i think they're
awesome i think i think the story is
good obviously like all the acting is
always good because they have amazing
actors the performances are always great
uh the visual effects on the other hand
are it's it they they
exist in this weird dichotomy of being
like literal
top grade effects but also slightly
generic
yeah totally when we did our marvel
versus or marvel rated r video
like i realized just how
cartoony i guess for lack of a better
words a lot of the visual effects were
not cartoony but like
see this is the thing you're like oh
visual effects how do you like
it's not about visual effects visual
effects are just tools to tell stories
it's like not about what you're seeing
but what's happening that's all it comes
down to and
in the marvel movies they work perfectly
well like they have a very flat
cinematography style it's very neutral
the visual effects in a weird way
kind of match that because once again
like they show the outstanding events
that are happening
to the characters and they treat them
as such so to speak they're like it's
it's
it's in the service of what's happening
on screen it just so happens that
what's happening on screen it has to do
with these incredible characters
so i don't know i'm i'm i'm i'm a huge
defender of these marvel movies that's
right i thought they're good too because
after like hearing how like
people are like crapping on superhero
movies and like all these directors like
oh it's not cinema it's like [ __ ] off
you know it's just like
it's just they're movies you don't have
to watch them
it's like every other thing people get
offended by this race it's like
just don't worry about it then it's not
affecting you
you know it's like but they're they're
they're incredibly well executed
so i mean arguably i mean the avengers
movies are great because a
they have a huge like backlog of
creative energy that's not even put into
those stories
yeah yeah very actually i think that's
the big [ __ ] point here these movies
have had decades and decades of story
writing that they embraced unlike star
wars
also unlike you know yeah i think that's
the big
[ __ ] jacked up part of the star wars
movies is they're like
hey let's just gonna we're gonna scrap
this whole universe of
that's mostly canon and like mostly
cohesive
and we're gonna just like rewrite all
this crap it's like
what why did you do that like there was
like so much thought and energy
already put into story writing here
that's like fantastic
yeah it's the same exact thing we saw
the game of thrones too but like
you know avengers has like i think
they're pulling a lot of infinity war
and end game from
90s comics i'm not mistaken but maybe it
goes into you know the 20s and the 2010s
well then
the infinity war issue yeah like the
first
series of issues like that story yeah so
they have all that to pull from and they
did
and like avengers is a character film at
the end of the day like they're all
character films and they're really well
executed character films
and so you know arguably the creative
energy has been put in to match the
visual energy of those films
yeah yeah i exactly and i think a very
clear
uh comparison can be drawn to dc movies
you know superman versus batman which
was definitely a
i started with the producer going what's
a cool title for a film
batman vs superman okay who can i hire
to write a story that matches the title
wait dude they already did i swear they
did comics for that i mean they did do
comics but
my point is that dc also has a huge
decades-old backlog of of great comics
with fantastic stories to draw from
the same practically the same as marvel
in in that
in terms of like what they can pull from
to get
great stories but why didn't dc do that
when marvel could
yeah dumb
[Laughter]
oh yeah so
i think as as somebody like on the
fringes of the industry it does make me
sad
when something comes out that just show
showcases
just people working for months and
months and months of their lives and
millions and millions of dollars spent
just to give me
the same pepperoni pizza i've eaten 100
times before
i was like you guys did a good job it's
a nice pepperoni pizza cooked well
pepperonis are on it there's cheese and
sauce crunchy
but it would have been cool that taste
of pizza flavor i've never tasted before
if you're gonna spend months making me a
pizza
[Laughter]
and there's a direct analogy to video
games too right now too where it's like
the same thing you know millions of
dollars and years of effort being put
into games well
maybe not years but you know millions of
dollars of effort in artistry being put
into video games are just the same exact
gameplay
sure yeah although i mean you know
it's pretty negative too it's like
what's all these [ __ ] dumb people
not making me a good film you know i
think it shows the
creative like i like the the the
scarcity of creativity
so to speak in a way where it's like it
shows hey it's hard to make things good
it's rare to make things good and yes
everyone's trying to do so
not everyone is succeeding on all fronts
by any standpoint but
you know it's it's through that same
system that creates that it also does
create
genius stuff as well and you know if
everyone could just go out and make
incredible films you know it's either
a well hold on if
everyone could just go and make
incredible films this world would be a
very different place we would have
had tesla cars like 300 years ago
probably
okay you know or would our uh would the
bar for excellence be
different where it's like even higher
there's just being another
point it's like i watched your movie and
i didn't get a telepathic message in my
sleep the next night it's like
you know it's like you're like like how
did you you know you didn't
lay they put all this energy into making
the film they didn't put any energy into
the telepathic resonance from it
yeah yeah i mean but seriously it's like
it just it would get even higher
it's either that or there's like maybe
two movies released every year i mean
arguably there's a bunch of great
filmmaking coming out it's just it's not
coming from the process
of somebody greenlighting a film because
of a business decision and then
forcing a creative process to happen
through that
with short time and then dumping money
and talent onto the
end of it which is just a totally
imbalanced way to approach making a
fight yeah
i agree well so here's here's a question
then um
what is your favorite movie to come out
in recent history like say this year
what's your favorite movie so far this
year
i didn't see any i saw little women this
year okay well then that's the only full
movie i watched this year
let me rephrase what is the last when
was the last time you saw a movie when
you're like wow
i think that might be my favorite movie
i've seen in a while
i'll start
[Laughter]
palm springs came out i need to check
that out i need to check it it is
probably my favorite movie i've seen
this year
it's basically what happens if you get
the lonely island guys to make groundhog
day yeah
i need to check it out it's it's very
good it because i mean
uh oh i know my answer okay good
but yeah my point is that like that
movie has some visual effects in it
there are some
some shots that are effects but they're
not like world-class effects there's a
few times where i'm like wow i could
have done that shot better
which kind of it's crazy this is a
hollywood movie this is a blockbuster
movie it was supposed to be a
blockbuster then kovid killed
blockbusters but uh that's why it's on
hulu
um it's uh
the story is good the characters are
great the direction is great
uh and but really it's just the story i
just i love the story so much
now i'm also a huge sucker for for time
repeating stories edge of tomorrow is
one of my favorite movies of all time oh
yeah i did recently watch groundhog day
for the first time
hated it did not like that movie
why is that i well okay part of it is
because it's like the first time someone
had ever
i i shouldn't say i i hated it i didn't
hate it i just
it didn't live up to the expectations
this is like the classic time
repeat story right but bill murray's
character is just
a dick yeah for too long in the movie
it's like he doesn't deserve the uh the
change of character that he gets by the
end of it when he's suddenly an angel
it's like he spends way too much the
movie being kind of creepy
and just being just a dick to everyone
and then but then the movie finally goes
into like oh yeah
like oh he's learning his his ways he oh
he learned how to become a master
pianist and all this stuff and
he's an angel now everyone said yeah you
don't like it i get it it's fine
i enjoyed it was the last time you saw
it uh whenever i would agree with your
assessment but as the first of its kind
it was great i do agree with that if it
was not for your first time seeing that
kind of movie you're like
i would also see that yeah yeah because
i did see groundhog day for the first
time
after watching both palm springs and
edge of tomorrow yeah
yeah tomorrow would ruin groundhog day
growing hogs day i don't yeah i i think
it's groundhog day
but i always said groundhog's day for
the longest time uh my movie of the year
so far be toy story
4. okay okay i watch that movie
uh once a week
what's up maybe once a week yeah
free movie love it no i i i
gideon loves it and yeah it's fantastic
and honestly like the concept of a
of what makes a toy alive like which is
just kind of
almost like a c story in the movie maybe
a b story like the fact they
went there and like had the freedom to
mess around with that
concept like i really like that you know
still has kind of the basic you know
gotta do the right thing and be there
for your friends and all that kind of
stuff but like
there's enough other fun things
happening around that main storyline
which they probably just kind of have to
put in there
that are like inventive that like okay
this is pretty rad
it's it's my favorite uh i was about to
say star wars movie toy story movie
there we go it's my favorite toy story
it's the best toy story movie for sure
and
and when i first voiced that i think i
tweeted about that whenever i first saw
the movie wanted to come out was it last
year 2019
sure i saw it after it came to blu-ray
um but i tweeted i was like it was my
favorite toy story movie by far i
thought it was incredible and everyone's
like
you liked it more than toy story three
how dare you
i was like what i wasn't that big of a
fan of toy story three i thought it was
okay
toy story three is trite compared to it
it's it's yeah
trite interesting yeah okay that's trite
you're like huh it's like it's like a
you know today toy story 2 is like okay
yeah it's like because toy story 3 is
just the same
story as the first two it's like the
same style of story so to speak where
it's like hey we're toys in another
wacky toy situation ha ha
barbie dolls you know it's like this one
the toy story 4
i don't know like it expands the
characters so much because it's
it's a completely different setting from
the first one which is like here's a
world
where like kids exists but aren't they
they but they're not in charge anymore
you know what i mean it's like
these it's like adult situations for
these toys so to speak
yeah um and it's pretty straightforward
to be made for
all age groups yeah plus it is by far
the best-looking pixar film ever made
yeah it is no context it's gorgeous dude
i saw it in hdr and
oh did you get away like the carnival
lights and everything yeah i really want
to
uh bring or do another animators react
maybe with eric
and have them break down the different
animations in toy story because there is
a master class of different styles of
animation like the ventriloquist dummies
animating one way versus like
i love those dummies the child's doll
versus another like versus like spoon
man you know
like whatever his name is sporky
porky like all of them and even woody's
animated like a marionette kinda
well not marrying up like a floppy rag
doll no they do the marionette animation
on them quite a lot where it's almost
like sometimes he defies gravity
yeah in a weird creepy way it's like
there's an invisible hand holding him
and shaking it yeah yeah and then of
course uh the stunt guy
voiced by keanu reeves like they're all
animated so differently
and each one has such like feeling and
character to the animation like
you take it for granted it's like oh
it's a ventriloquist dummy of course it
moves that way it's like wait a minute
somebody had to figure out how to make
it move with that character yeah like
it's like the limp heads that like it's
like if they're if they're not being
driven they like
go limp yeah like yeah those details are
incredible
in that film well also it's like anytime
you think of a pixar movie there's a
very distinct aesthetic you think of
it's like that cg
look of like kind of clay and they can
make it away with it
they they haven't done that clay look in
decades
really like the first toy story and even
the second toy store was kind of like
the last
like movies that really kind of uh
didn't really have texture because i
remember seeing a special about
toy story 3 how it's like it still has
that sort of
fake look but all of the individual
materials and textures are all hyper
real
yeah and it's like it's a weird way to
balance that where it's like
i think it's just once again
cinematography yeah i think it comes
a lot down to that it's like yes you can
have your rendering quality you can have
your visual effects
it's all about how you're shooting it
and communicating on screen it always
has to pass through this quote-unquote
lens
and that filter can skew your reaction
to a
shot or a scene or visual effect in any
direction
it's like wall-e is i think the only
other one that's kind of like
in that same level their rendering
quality in wally isn't as high
and just because it's you know 12 years
ago but
the way they shot it if once again i
watch wally
uh once a day right now
[Laughter]
i always put it on what 8 30 p.m we
watch wall-e
we've been doing that every night for
like the last week because he freaking
loves wall-e right now i do that every
night with your son
every night i watch wall-e with your son
[Laughter]
um but wally in in all seriousness it
they have that very it's someone with a
very good cinema background basically
dp'ed that
well even for like for toy story four
they specifically like develop these
looks
that replicate the look of lenses and
film yeah yeah and
and you know they even had freaking like
split diopter shots in toy story four
did you watch the nerd writer video
about it i did
it's been a long time but that was what
pointed me out so i was like that is
true holy crap
yeah it's pretty nuts yeah they they
went all out and
and it's like those are things you can
do in camera
uh split diopters where you have like a
piece of glass covering half
of the the lens and so that makes it so
you can have two different spots at two
different depths both be in focus
with a a sleeve down the middle that you
ideally can't see
in visual effects or in cg stuff you can
do
whatever you want but they'd
specifically emulated
the split diopter look to maintain that
sort of uh visual consistency with all
the other lensed
shots yeah in the movie totally somebody
must have seen the lego movie and it's
like oh
okay fine we'll make it look like that
yeah basically
lego movie that's right that was a good
one that was okay that's a movie
that had great effects and a great story
yeah yeah
lego movie is also i think one of those
animated films that came out it's like
guys you can make your
cg look photo real people will still
enjoy it as a cartoon
and pixar's like okay fine i'll turn
i'll check the global illumination box
finally
yeah i'm just kidding they've had
radiology and all that stuff in there
forever
but yeah i mean that just goes back to
what i was saying is like you know if
you actually like look close at every
individual texture or material
in and even toy story three or whatever
other movies came out around that same
time it's like
that texture is how that texture
actually looks like in real life
but the combination of all of the
textures that make up the final scene
still give you that pixar aesthetic that
doesn't look
photoreal it's just kind of it's kind of
weird how that happens
i think it's because the lighting itself
is detached from realism not that they
aren't rendering the lights individually
individually with the realistic
parameters but there's unrealistic
lighting in the scene yes
okay i character will be at one light
level there'll be lights shining on
somebody that
aren't visible yeah right yeah yeah it's
the same thing that happened to the
dinosaurs in jurassic world where it's
just like
there are light sources on these
dinosaurs that are not hitting anything
else in the scene but the dinosaur
that that velociraptor uh blends in too
much with the background can you had a
bit of an
edge light on him there isn't a light in
the scene to motivate that doesn't
matter dude
yeah i got a script that turned out in
one week for you guys to work on
the andrastic world was such a
disappointment to me that was one where
i was like excited for it and literally
walked up being like that
wasn't a good movie and it was a
disappointment to me to come to terms
with that thought
yeah yeah i just this is my hope that
people will spend more time
uh making films because they have a
great idea for a film as opposed to
making films because they
think this idea will make money and then
they figure out an idea that fits the
mold after the fact
yeah and that just comes down to the
industry right it's like you know
that's why we're seeing fewer and fewer
films get made at
smaller budgets of you know 5 to 50
million because
the money is all in the blockbusters
because people are going to see movies
fewer you know less frequently you're
seeing your customers are going to
survive covet
i think they'll come back i think i
think we'll see a surge once people are
feel safe going back to theaters i think
the whole world or the whole country at
the very least we'll just
embrace it every every cinema right now
every
company is just holding on waiting for
that to be for them to be the ones to
finally
last to the end and be the one i mean
it's like what i've always said is like
the moment i can safely and morally
attend a party
i'm going to a party i don't care where
that party is i'm attending it
and i have a feeling dude i love sewer
parties
give me some pizza and mutant ninja
turtles some new
yeah but like i i think people
having been denied movie theaters for so
long will come back
it'll be a surge and then it'll go back
to the way it was beforehand mm-hmm as
long as
and then they'll slowly die and then
video on demand through this whole time
period
i was like you know what's gonna be cool
paying 30 bucks for mulan
moonland mulan
[Laughter]
got mulan and jimmy yeah no i support
jimmy and all his endeavors but i'm just
saying it's kind of silly to pay 30
bucks for a movie to see on the internet
i won't wait until december i don't need
to i mean i don't know if if tennant
came out and it was like hey it's 30
bucks i'd be like
if it was really okay you're right i
paid 30 bucks
yeah okay you're right i probably
wouldn't come out it's just it's just
yeah not my not my thing we'll see maybe
my son will like it and i'll be forced
to watch it every night
i watch it every night oh no i meant
mulan
daddy daddy put on uh put on mo line i'm
done kirk again
show me the scene where the pilot
crashes one more time
daddy can you dunkirk was a movie i was
also slightly disappointed in did you
guys see that one
i enjoyed it i loved what it did with
the variable time frames but like i kind
of walked out of that movie kind of just
feeling
it's a movie that i don't have any
desire to watch that was it that that's
exactly it i i enjoyed watching it i
think i like the movie
i'm probably never going to watch it
again sure but would you watch gravity
again
yeah probably okay i've watched i've
watched shots from gravity
okay yeah yeah yeah because like they're
kind of in the same way pain
where they're like survival stories
where like you watch them you're like
that was intense and you're like it's
like you don't go like you want to watch
that again
like it's like no i'm good it was
intense
like i was on the edge of my seat the
whole time and it was it was
in at times actually kind of
uncomfortable it was so effective
everest did you guys ever see everest
one of the most tense movies i've ever
seen
it's about these guys trying to climb
everest and half of them die but like
it's it's a real story but it was like i
i i was
so soaking wet from sweating
all right all right well good movies
that's our musings on uh the state of
the industry and what i guess what it
takes to make a visual effects
shot be good turns out why don't you
make a better movie if you think you
could complain about others
i'll keep working on it okay i'm getting
better little by little i mean that is a
very common and
prevalent criticism that is the ultimate
criticism it's like how dare you
criticize movies if you can't do better
yourself well no seriously like
i think i mean as far as like somebody
who understand like trying to understand
storytelling through film
i'm i think i'm just barely starting to
get there like barely
no seriously like i feel like with
tactical three loads
yeah you monster and like kind of just
going back to like
meemon like i didn't write that but like
you know it was like the past two years
or so i feel like
myself and honestly all of us as a group
like we're starting to understand
story on film a little bit better and
this is you saying that after
15 years of doing it yes there's a lot
of things i did not understand until
recently and honestly it's like going
back and doing the simple stories
and just doing them well and functional
and like making sure like is your
do you have suspension of disbelief does
anything distract you from the story
does it flow and is it fun
and do you follow the emotional arcs yes
cool then it's fine if it's the most
basic story in the world
i'm going to start with that and then
we'll work from there you know
but if you're james cameron you're
banned from doing that oh i mean come on
james cameron
a little bit i'm joking i'm joking i'm
just playing around
just playing around all i can say is i
hope avatar 2
involves an avatar going back in time to
protect a young human child how about
this
alien hunts them down that's a good idea
hold that thought
we can put your
theory and your story to the test let's
let's do this i want you to help me beat
james cameron
to avatar 2 with a better story all
right let's do it okay
oh boy we're gonna do it oh boy this is
an idea we've had for the crew channel
and it seems like this podcast is a
great kicking off point
avoid it so don't forget those those
avatar people the na'vi are like 10 feet
tall so if you're if you're
motion capping that i'm going to retcon
that we'll figure that out
you might still fall back on having an
ai write the script but we'll edit it
i like that idea a lot because then any
any blame
you put on the ai not you no what if you
actually edit an ai script and then like
go like no like we're actually trying to
make it better
like how do we actually really really
try and make this good
anyways whatever i'm done dude what the
ai script is good how is that going to
shake us to the core
well yeah alrighty cool well everybody
thank you for listening to the podcast
hope you guys enjoyed it we'll see you
in the next one
bye-bye thanks for watching thanks for
listening and
cut